una plaza vacía Y una promesa de
austeridad Jeff recibe la temporada
navideña sin luces ni adornos el centro
de la capital ucraniana suele hacer gala
de un enorme árbol de navidad de más de
30 metros esta vez ante los ataques
rusos a la infraestructura ucraniana su
tamaño se verá reducido a más de la
mitad y estará adornado con símbolos del
ejército ucraniano una muestra simbólica
de la crisis energética que vivió
Ucrania y Europa la llegada de un
invierno inusual preocupa al viejo
continente en donde se han anunciado
posibles cortes de Electricidad Y aunque
el panorama parece gris las autoridades
de algunos países europeos hacen un
llamado a la calma No entren en pánico
eso no tiene sentido
hay un trabajo legítimo realizado por el
gobierno para prepararse para casos
extremos que es por supuesto la
necesidad de cortar la electricidad
durante algunas horas en el día Es
normal que el gobierno se prepare para
un caso extremo porque como nos han
demostrado los últimos años a veces
sucede lo impensable
en paralelo Europa Busca soluciones
Bélgica inaugura la mayor planta de
almacenamiento de energía eléctrica de
Europa continental afuera de una pequeña
ciudad belga estos contenedores son
capaces de satisfacer la demanda máxima
del país un paso hacia la transición
energética hasta ahora la capacidad de
producir rápidamente significaba muchas
centrales eléctricas de petróleo o
centrales eléctricas de gas que
activamos en cualquier momento con este
nuevo tipo de Central eléctrica es
posible prescindir por completo de los
combustibles fósiles ante una posible
crisis energética la comisión europea
planteó Establecer un tope para los
precios de gas en toda la Unión Europea
una determinación que ha generado
choques entre los ministros de energía
de muchos de los países miembros